one of these drinks was lovingly crafted
by a bartender while the other one was
generated using AI here's how it works
each Patron inputs some of their
preferences into a Google form that info
is given both directly to the bartender
and run through chat GPT 4 both come up
with their own custom cocktail recipes
the bartender then mixes both drinks and
the patron receives the two cocktails
it's then up to them to decide which
drink is the human cocktail and which is
p
that was an odd
[Music]
jump hi hi welcome hey how's it going
good how are you I'm Robert welcome to
punch in your info how difficult should
I make this as crazy as you can get
bring it I'm
excited all right so she wants something
Smoky sultry fruity and surprise me so
it sounds to me like she likes things
that are Citrus forward Smoky so things
I'm thinking she likes mcal margarita so
I'm going to use that and kind of play
with that concept like a margarita time
10 let's see what AI wants me to do all
right so 1 oz mcal 1 oz tequila 1 oz uzo
1 oz vodka has a lot of booze so this
will kill somebody 1 oz lime juice 2 oz
pomegranate juice oh wants me to stir
this drink that's interesting we don't
stir things with juice in them but screw
it let's do what AI
wants pretty color though reminds me of
like a prickly
pear all right ready to
go we don't know who can read your mind
and who can't we'll see who won thank
you does it say underneath it which
one's which okay I will not
peek okay this one's really like spicy
love
spicy
ooh cohesive human dissonant
AI
yes I was right I'm going to not enjoy
this one and I will enjoy this one thank
you all right whoever's next come on up
hey how's it going hello Mr guest person
how are you yeah let's see what you got
[Music]
going I'll have these whipped up for you
in a
second he's excited and he's ready for a
surprise distress and have fun I don't
know what that means nothing to avoid no
allergies ready to unwind all right I'm
probably going to keep this light cuz he
also said he's in a festive
[Music]
mood let's see what AI wants me to do
it's having me mix literally Scotch
vodka and Jin all together and I don't
feel like they mix very well but who am
I to
judge all right AI I see you
good to
go oo they look
[Music]
beautiful oh wow that's great M so but
yes a human actually made this one
because it tastes better AI it's like
not cohesive but I'm going to be really
sad if I'm wrong this here is a human
because this one is a surprise and this
one a little less I'm going to go with
this being AI because it's a bold swing
and a bold Miss I'm going to say that
this one is AI I said that I like citrus
flavors and it feels like the Citrus was
just kind of like put in but not built
in this tastes pretty much like in a
gron which is what I said I liked so I
think maybe the AI was just going right
off my prop so we'll
[Music]
see oh my god really AI I was wrong AI
I do like the AI one much better no no
this one is the the human Okay K oh you
got it backwards oh brother human wow I
was right how cool ah boom yeah yes ai
ai oh I'm sorry AI not taking our jobs
yet this is human I got it right there
you go hey Robert I got
you the difference between a bartender
making a drink say an AI making a drink
is maybe the personal aspect you can
kind of feel the person and therefore I
can kind of mirror or kind of absorb
some of the energy from that person and
then kind of get creative with it and I
haven't noticed too much creativity with
the AI though there's been a couple
situations it did get pretty creative I
thought it was
interesting